some truly haunting images coming in
here folks millions around the planet
have reportedly disappeared the exact
numbers right now are uncertain we've
lost several world leaders from some of
our brightest minds and most of the
Golden State Warriors I'm now noticing
some people here on our studio are now
turning into dust themselves Oh God
there there goes Rand alert line
producer
I remember when Randall slept with my
wife at last year's company Christmas
party starting to look like everyone in
our studio here is gone except for me Oh
No
oh there it is I'm turning the dust as
well somebody get me an urn because I'm
about to be ash
this is Burt Burton Sandberg signing oh
that was how it all began everything was
just spiraling out of control it all
happened so fast I turn around I was
gonna ask my friend what happened
there's no one there
I look over to my homie yo he's not
there people sort of turned clouds of
dust it was pretty cool actually I was
in the middle of signing the divorce
papers and uh
let's just say I got the house and and
one of the five kids four of them
earlier this year on a day that will be
long remembered half of the world's
population suddenly disappeared one by
one and some more dramatically and
drawn-out than others billions of people
found themselves fading away into dust
after the dust settled literally it was
discovered that the Avengers versus
mightiest heroes had failed to save us
from an attack from Thanos the guy
everyone on YouTube pretended to know
everything about in 2012 for six years
Stannis apparently sat around and sat
around till he finally summoned the
courage to get up from his lazy boy
throne and fulfill his evil quest that
day he arrived in Wakanda
with just one snap of his fingers
carried out his evil plan and
disappeared shortly thereafter there was
no word on what Thanos is up to now but
one could assume he is sitting down
again but this film isn't about what
happened on that fateful afternoon this
is about those who were left behind here
on earth yeah I was at the Lakers game
when the big Dan oh snap happened I was
walking through Target and I look around
and like before I knew it half the store
was just empty there's still too many
[ __ ] here you know I mean I mean I
mean I lost some friends but I think fan
OHS could have made it 75% instead of 50
I was working in the lab cleaning up the
myths from the fight that he had we came
manga it was glass everywhere and I had
to clean up the job and serious things
she had clothes and shoes and everything
and beads all over the place it was
actually during the broadcast of the
Miss America pageant
stupid Stephanie Miss New Jersey was up
there
accepting the crown and then
this was something that I had worked
really hard for and I'm nothing if not
an opportunist so I see it's my
opportunity to take what was really
rightfully mine look over to the front
row Jack Nicholson caught half the squad
gone
guess who survived though LeBron James
survived the snap you know I don't care
man I lost all my family my homies lost
the entire hood I don't care man as long
as I have to see LeBron play one last
game that's all that matters
I don't want to sound speciesist or
anything I mean some of my friends our
Chitauri are using and as Guardians as
tough but you know I think we got a new
motto now post Thanos and that's make
earth human again you know a lot of
people think I should feel lucky that I
survived the snap I feel like half the
person I was it's been taken away from
me and I think the biggest reason for
that I don't know where my lower half is
so where did the dissapeared go did they
all simply die did they travel into
another dimension
recently a cult called the guilty
remnant has emerged claiming to have all
of the answers their members wear white
clothing and don't speak but Lee gird
Police Chief Kevin Garvey was formerly
married to one of the cult claims that
the this is just the plot of the
leftovers who who put this in charlie
you son of a [ __ ] once it was revealed
that Thanos was behind the attack this
question had to be posed why why did
this bald purple alien southpaw with
strangely perfect white teeth wish to
destroy so many of us his goal was to
like only leave around the half that are
actually worth keeping around I made it
through I'm having fun of the 50% that
survived so I got a like the guy he sued
it's not the other people the people who
made all the trouble in Wakanda
we could have welcomed to me man give
him a
what Jesus Christ we have rhinos for him
I would certainly thank him for keeping
the preferred half you know it'd be a
little weird during the interview it was
just like a talking penis I guess I'll
tell you one thing though the way daños
took out the galaxy he's a big baller
brand support it he probably got the KX
he probably got the t-shirts
big baller brand big ballin Lonzo ball
RP I know the purple guy animals down in
these two coffee mugs right they're not
folks they traveled containers but use
them for coffee are using to piss it
good on them I mean that's the world
we're living in now I mean you want
something you go out there and you get
it
boom it happens my wife is gone it's
like well that [ __ ] worked out that
knows he's just a man like the rest of
us he is a person of color who has
misunderstood what is wrong with you
is supposed to be what Conda forever
standard for the revolution damn it Don
owes you look at how Great America has
become now that we have eliminated half
of the population I mean I think just
based on like the statistics of the kind
of people who I've seen that are still
around it's like you have to meet like a
certain pretty quotient to keep living
and honestly everybody nobody needs ugly
people we did receive word than Iron Man
himself Tony Stark has survived the
attack and is alive on a distant planet
called Titan one of our reporters was
able to connect with start via Skype
okay basically this is what happened you
know everything was normal like
completely normally nothing's going on
in this big purple guy white dot half
the universe I didn't do it I didn't
have any to do it something dad would
have done you know I'm gonna say they're
not dead because I don't wanna like
scare anyone but they are they're dead
so basically none of this is my fault
star-lord made a mistake it's a rookie
mistake it's like running in on a punt
and it's not a bunch o guy hits the line
driver hit her in the face
this is what he did basically you know
he tried to get the club off and it was
a mistake and lost the game I mean it's
a world series but you know okay no it's
dead I don't hold grudges so what
happens now where does the world and go
from here will the Avengers save us will
there be an insanely elaborate
time-traveling mission that will
magically fix everything and make us go
on like no
remember what's next for the world I
mean I think LeBron still gonna take the
championship I think it's gonna be a
straight run to the finals my life is
not change I just have more stuff to
clean
I am fully prepared to lead the new
America in this great future that we
have ahead of us you know I hear these
Asgardians they have a they have a
bridge and as guardian or wherever the
hell they're from how about we build a
wall around the Milky Way
keep these aliens out hopefully I can
get my own black panther suit I know I'm
a little thicker but you know what maybe
I can beat the black Pam you know say
there's no problem with that by the way
you would not believe how quickly you
can get an uber now that I mean again I
like I lost loved ones everybody did but
the way I get around town now is is I
guess one of the benefits you know this
world is scary so you gotta not be
scared go out and party
I swear think this is the remembrance of
the Falcon and potentially a little bit
of the white boy with one arm put him in
a nice pile together cleanliness is next
to godliness
[Music]
it's so stupid sometimes I just go in
the bathroom and I sit where I used to
take it if anything that's better than
you know not being here I guess so
LeBron
[Music]